it has been called the game changer in
the fight
against coronavirus and is a major hope
for a return to a more normal way of
life by spring well in the last few
minutes i'm pleased to say
that the rollout of the oxford
astrazeneca vaccine has begun
in the uk and this is the first
vaccination to be given
[Applause]
university hospital and let me introduce
you
well this is the oxford university
hospital and
let me introduce you to brian pinker
aged 82 a retired maintenance manager
who describes himself as
appropriately oxford born and bred now
he became the very first
person to be vaccinated by nonetheless
than the hospital's
chief nurse at the beginning a very
important milestone
uh in the vaccination program uh brian
said follow i'm so pleased to be getting
the covered vaccine today really proud
that it's one that was invented in
oxford
the nurses doctors and staff today have
all been brilliant
and i can now really look forward to
celebrating my 48th
wedding anniversary with my wife charlie
later this year brian not the only
person receiving
at the vaccine this morning also music
teacher father of three trevor cowlett
aged 88 and interestingly professor
andrew pollard
a pediatrician working at oxford
university hospital
who also pioneered the oxford jam at
those
among the first to be vaccinated today
let's bring in our health correspondent
ashish joshi as we continue to watch
those pictures of the of the first
vaccination taking place we say it quite
enough quite often when talking about
covert 19 but a milestone and one worth
marking
yes it's a historic day there's no other
way of looking at this
obviously three very proud patients who
were receiving the first
vaccinations as you were saying this is
the one that's been described as the
government as
a game changer and there are reasons for
this this is
a homegrown vaccination heavily backed
by the government
right the way through this pandemic this
is the one that's
affordable this is the one that's
accessible and
this is the one that will be rolled out
to gp surgeries as soon as the first few
hospital trusts
receive the first 530 doses of the
vaccine
six hospital trusts have been identified
and after that into next week
we'll see gp hubs rolling out this
vaccine
to those people who have been described
as vulnerable the elderly healthcare
workers
this is really the the big boost that
the government needs in its vaccination
program we've had
the fisa vaccine rolled out three and a
half weeks ago this is the one that will
be available
in numbers the government says it's
ordered already
100 million doses and have 40 million
doses in play by the end of march
so into the spring when we hope to see
the the
end really of the the health crisis
which has gripped this country for the
last
year or so this is because this vaccine
can be transported at fridge temperature
unlike the other vaccines it doesn't
need to be
stored in super fridges at minus 70
degrees this is at normal fridge
temperatures
this is much cheaper than all the other
vaccines it's affordable
and because it's a home-grown vaccine
they will have the numbers
that they need to make this immunization
program a mass
immunization program get it into the
arms of the people who need it most so
there's a lot of hope around this
vaccine
and it really couldn't come at a more
critical time
in in the fight against coronavirus in
this country i mean
you say that correctly you know there is
a real pressing need to get this vaccine
in the arms of as many people as
possible as soon as possible
but it was a few days ago that this was
cleared for use why has there been this
lag time
between this uh all-important vaccine
being cleared for use and it actually
going into the arm of
uh as we said we've got some new
pictures coming in just now we saw brian
pinker
a little bit earlier on but it's taken
quite a while to get into the hospitals
there has been a number of days between
the mhra clearing this vaccine for use
and to get this vaccine into these
hospital trusts the first ones
identified
and then later on into the gp hubs that
we've been talking about we don't know
what the
the reason for that uh delay of several
days is
these things work very quickly the mhra
has had to work very fast it's become
the first
regulatory body to approve this vaccine
we can only presume that it had to make
sure
that this vaccine was transported from
where it's been manufactured
into these hospital trusts and it's
ready we know it's safe
because it's been cleared by the mhra
but we don't know why there's been a lag
but we have been told
that the other thing about this vaccine
which is really important to understand
is that the second dose has been a lot
of controversy around the dosing
uh regime around these vaccines this one
is the one where they have
up to 12 weeks to get the second dose
into the arms of these patients so
there is that window of opportunity
they'll get as many people
vaccinated as quickly as possible with
the first dose and then the second dose
which
oxford astrazeneca say is is
available for use up to 12 weeks after
the first test that is a really
important window for this vaccine that
means they can get it out
into as many people as possible and give
them a level of protection
up to 60 to 70 percent a level of
efficacy for that first days and then
get that second dose in as well there's
been a lot of talk
about the the government um working with
pfizer to change the dosing interval
for the pfizer vaccine which some people
say
is wrong scientists are coming around to
it the government says it's safe
we had professor jonathan van tam
writing about it over the weekend
saying it's absolutely crucial to get
these vaccines both of them
into as much of the population as
possible and that's why we've seen this
this delay with the the announcement
with the the dosing
uh regime at the moment